stasera è bellissimo opportunità e
raccontare con la cui sto dedicando la
mia vita con passione con entusiasmo
giornate intere passate in laboratorio a
studiare materiali per le batterie del
futuro o ancora grossa responsabilità
perché vi parleremo di ricerca di
frontiera di ricercatori di migliaia di
ricercatori nel mondo in italia in prima
linea a dedicare energie proprio per
sviluppare quei sistemi che sono
considerati i più efficienti per
l'accumulo dell'energia e sono in
particolare le batterie litio ione però
prima io vi chiedo di aiutarmi ad
esaudire un desiderio nascosto
mi piacerebbe un sacco
se poteste accendere la torcia dei
cellulari come si fa ai concerti fanno
parte la canzone lenta perché a voi
capite voi siete è prima volta un palco
guarda che meraviglia
ovviamente grazie grazie grazie
bellissimo che però so che qualcuno di
voi non lo ha fatto perché preoccupato
che il telefono si scarica e poi dopo
non riesce più a localizzare dove ha
messo la macchia che magari è un'auto
elettrica
uno scenario impensabile 40 anni fa se
andava a teatro o ai concerti
sicuramente non con l'auto la bici
elettrica si faceva luce con gli
accendini
ecco quelle che noi abbiamo assistito
siamo all'interno di una nuova
rivoluzione industriale il cui cuore sta
nelle batterie che sono la tecnologia di
volta per rendere
regia disponibile a tutti
indipendentemente dalle risorse dei
paesi per disegnare città pulite quindi
trasporto elettrico pensare a nuove
politiche energetiche sostenibili che
affrontino le problematiche relative ai
cambiamenti climatici
e proprio questo quello a cui punta la
l'agenda nazionale
l'agenda dell'onu 2030 per la
sostenibilità che disegna una visione
del futuro sostenibile come il valore
condiviso imprescindibile per affrontare
le sfide dei paesi in un contesto
globale un futuro realizzabile mediante
lo sviluppo di tecnologie innovative
legate all'energia pulita
infatti è indubbio che la crescita dei
paesi sia assolutamente legata alla
disponibilità dell'energia elettrica nel
2050 si stima che era il momento dei
consumi tra doppierà principalmente a
causa in carico ai paesi non ocse e al
fine di rendere l'energia disponibile a
tutti una possibilità è quella di
migliorare lo sfruttamento delle fonti
energetiche rinnovabili nel 2050 il 50
per cento del fabbisogno sarà
soddisfatto dal sole dal vento ma solo
evento sono discontinui e quindi
necessita dono di un sistema di accumulo
che accumuli nell'energia per poi
erogarla al bisogno in modo controllato
ad esempio questo lo può fare una
batteria
prendiamo un pannello fotovoltaico
durante le ore diurne
l'energia solare convertiti in energia
elettrica viene accumulata nella
batteria
l'accumulo e poi la può erogare
nelle ore notturne ad esempio
parallelamente la il bisogno di
disegnare politiche energetiche
sostenibili che non indipendenti dal
petrolio che diminuiscano le emissioni
serra ha fatto sì che i trasporti siano
stati trasformati gradualmente in
elettrico nel 2030 in europa metà delle
auto saranno elettrica e quelle vendute
e si stima si raggiungano i 23 milioni
di unità autonomia di percorso e costo
delle auto elettriche sono determinate e
saranno determinate dalle batterie che
le alimenteranno ecco quindi che la
disponibilità energetica sfruttamento
delle fonti rinnovabili veicoli
elettrici sono tutti ambiti nei quali
maggiori progressi sono stati ottenuti
grazie agli avanzamenti ottenuti in 40
anni di ricerche non specifico settore
che quello delle batterie al litio ione
40 anni per una rivoluzione industriale
lenta lunga da conquistare ma che è
stata riconosciuta proprio dieci giorni
fa con l'attribuzione del premio no per
la chimica ai tre pionieri della ricerca
delle batterie litio ione e il 1980
quando il professor good enough di
oxford pubblica questo articolo che
vedete sulla sinistra
in questo articolo si dimostra per la
prima volta la possibilità di disegnare
batterie litio ione con l'energia
specifica anche quattro volte superiori
a quelle delle batterie al piombo che
all'epoca erano quelle più diffuse
io allora avevo 10 anni inconsapevole di
quanto questo articolo avrebbe cambiato
la mia vita personale e professionale e
sociale
volevo fare la pianista non avrei mai
pensato che 40 anni dopo sarei stato il
teatro
di suonare a parlarvi a raccontarvi
delle batterie del futuro questo
sicuramente no
in questo articolo
il professor good enough dimostrava che
nostro di cobalto è in grado di
accumulare carica reversibilmente
scambiando contemporaneamente ioni litio
quindi è possibile pensare alla batteria
le quali due elettrodi accumulano
energia elettrica scambiando gli oneri
chi non verso e durante la carica e
durante la scarica la distribuiscono
l'energia scambiando ioni litio nel
verso opposto quindi dai due elettrodi
durante la carica e la scarica e ioni
litio dondolano in un verso o nell'altro
nel caso appunto di una carico della
scarica
ecco quindi da qui il concetto di
batteria sedia a dondolo e vero che in
cera batteri ora sony intuì la grande
potenzialità di questa tecnologia e ci
vogliono dieci anni 11 anni affinché lo
mettesse sul mercato è il primo settore
individuato era quello dell'elettronica
di consumo
in questa batteria se potevano disporre
i materiali su strati ab affiancati e
che poi venivano in qualche modo
arrotolati ho ripiegato in modo tale da
confinare una grande quantità di energia
in un piccolo volume nel 1990 avevo 20
anni
avevo deciso di dedicare la mia
creatività artistica alla chimica e
nei telefoni cellulari iniziavano ad
essere diffusi le auto elettriche
sicuramente no
i telefoni cellulari però erano grandi
ingombranti e pesanti si scaricavano
molto in fretta tant'è che esistevano
ancora le cabine telefoniche e la
funzionalità di questi telefoni cellula
era fondamentalmente limitata dalle
batterie che utilizzavano che all'epoca
lì all'inizio non ero sicuramente
batterie agli ioni litio ma da quegli
anni ad oggi sono stati fatti enormi
passi nel materiale per le batterie al
litio ione e le prestazioni di queste
batterie sono aumentate incredibilmente
tant'è che è stato possibile aprire
nuovi settori per il loro uso per
l'elettronica di consumo ai veicoli
elettrici a applicazioni industriali e
ad altri settori
ora parallelamente il mercato delle
batterie litio ione cresciuto
esponenzialmente tra cinque anni si
stima raggiungerà i 100 miliardi di
dollari
ma questi altri settori richiedono nuove
batterie nuove idee nuovi concetti di
batterie ed è proprio quello su cui sto
lavorando da tanti anni e negli ultimi
dieci anni insieme a francesca de
giorgio
[Applauso]
nel 2009 a pochi chilometri da qui è
partito un nuovo progetto di ricerca
sulle batterie del futuro
le batterie ricaricabili litio aria le
batterie ricavi di litio aria sono delle
batterie molto promettenti e innovative
perché permettono di raggiungere insita
energia significativamente superiori
rispetto a quelle delle batterie litio
ione che ci sono adesso in commercio che
ci possono garantire delle autonomie di
percorso massimo di 500 km
ma non sono ancora sufficienti e tutti
noi che avremo un auto elettrica non
saremo soddisfatti da questo da questo
rende così basso
bene le batterie ricaricabili litio aria
che vengono anche chiamate batterie
litio ossigeno possono garantire delle
autonomie di percorso anche superiori a
700 chilometri perché hanno delle
densità di energia che possono arrivare
anche a cinque volte superiori quelle
delle batterie di turone secondo il
piano d'azione è delineato dalla
commissione europea
le tipologie di batterie al litio sono
divise in generazioni
noi sul mercato adesso abbiamo le
batterie al litio di seconda generazione
e le batterie di ossigeno vengono
considerate batteria di quinta
generazione che verranno
commercializzati a partire dal 2030
possiamo quindi definire le batterie del
futuro però per portarle sul mercato
abbiamo bisogno del lavoro sinergico e
della collaborazione di più persone di
più competenze che provengono dal mondo
sia accademico che industriale e di
notevoli investimenti
d'altra parte l'innovazione nel mondo
delle batterie è un percorso molto lungo
e progressivo
infatti la prima volta che è stata
dimostrata una batteria liti ossigeno
ricaricabile
nel 1996 quando due ricercatori
scienziati americani hanno dimostrato il
funzionamento della prima batteria litio
ossigeno e sono stati i primi a compiere
il grande passo verso le batterie del
futuro solo cinque anni dopo la prima
commercializzazione delle batterie litio
ione ma allora ci chiediamo come mai
queste batterie rivoluzioneranno da
energetica è semplice non c'è bisogno di
immagazzinarlo all'interno della nostra
batteria perché proviene dall'area
dall'ambiente esterno adesso bene
questo fa sì che queste batterie abbiano
delle dimensioni più piccole dei volumi
più piccoli rispetto alle batterie che
ci sono ora in commercio e le rendono
estremamente leggere aumentandone il
contenuto energetico
io nel 96 e ragazzi agli 11 anni
affascinata dal mondo delle scienze che
guardava con estrema ammirazione
gli scienziati questi giganti che
contribuiscono al progresso tecnologico
della nostra società
nel 96 la qantas poi la ricerca ha
continuato sviluppare e nuove ricerche
sulle batterie litio aria in importanti
laboratori di ricerca internazionali
negli stati uniti in giappone in canada
e anche in italia in quegli anni tra il
2016 e 2017 sono stati depositati alcuni
brevetti sulle batterie l'ici e anche
qui in quegli anni nello stesso
laboratorio dove nel 2009 erano in tutti
gli studi è stato depositato un brevetto
un brevetto totalmente innovativo che
dimostrava un nuovo concetto innovativo
di batteria ricaricabile liti ossigeno
perché stiamo parlando della prima
batteria liti ossigeno liquida
ricaricabile che fa il pieno di energia
questa batteria ha una densità di
energia di 500 wattora kg
ora vorrei che voi chiudesse un attimo
gli occhi e provate ad immaginare di
avere un'auto elettrica alimentata da
questa batteria liquida potrete partire
da bologna è raggiunto
per le spiagge del salento con un unico
pieno senza aver bisogno di dovervi
fermare a metà percorso per ricaricare
la vostra batteria a ripe destinazione
vi recherete alla stazione di
rifornimento qui consegnerei li potrete
svuotare il liquido dello scarico della
vostra batteria e sostituirlo con un
nuovo liquido carico né se fosse un
normale pieno di benzina riducendo così
i lunghi tempi di ricarica il liquido
scarico invece lo consegnerete alla
stazione di rifornimento e qui sarà
ricaricato da altre batterie liquide
mediante la rete di fonti rinnovabili
una volta ricaricato il vostro liquido
sarà pronto per un nuovo pieno e per un
nuovo lungo viaggio
ora capite bene che tutto questo
rivoluzionerà il mondo delle energetica
cambi radicalmente il paradigma perché
porterà ad un nuovo concetto di energia
liquida ricaricabile il liquido che
diventa un vettore di energia è una
batteria verde perché non utilizza gli
elementi critici e metalli pesanti che
utilizzano attualmente le batterie e
inoltre contiene elettrodi liquidi che
devono essere prodotti attraverso i
costosi processi produttivi che servono
per produrre le batterie al litio
quindi questo fa sì che si riducano i
costi le emissioni di energia di
anidride carbonica tutto in italy
economia circolare bene
provate ad immaginare che tutto questo
parta da qui io e francesca da bambina
non avremmo mai potuto immaginare
ma essa un portando avanti un progetto
imprenditoriale perché puntiamo a
precorrere i tempi portando sul mercato
è un cambio di paradigma nelle allergie
tica che porta in sé asia liquida alla
portata di tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]